élève de l'école nationale de
l'administration emmanuel cau le plateau
est en stage à la préfecture des
yvelines
ce jour-là à chanteloup les vignes elle
rend visite à des personnes formées aux
métiers de la restauration
un encadrement assuré par deux chefs
cuisiniers avec une formation de
quelques semaines vous arrivez à vous y
retrouver les potentiels et à les
accompagner vers la semaine dans un
hôtel un patron comme le nôtre on voit
tout de suite si la personne confie
groupe
cette formation s'inscrit dans le cadre
du dispositif quartiers d'été un dossier
dont s'est occupé emmanuel cau le
plateau dans la mise en oeuvre sur le
département
objectif renforcer les actions à
destination du public des quartiers
politique de la ville suite à la crise
sanitaire
vous veillez à la bonne mise en place de
ces actions sur le terrain à la mise en
relation des responsables des
associations avec les partenaires locaux
et avec l'aide des délégués du préfet et
j'ai veillé à ce que ses actions
puissent se mettre en oeuvre rapidement
après cette visite retour à la
sous-préfecture de saint-germain-en-laye
à 32 ans elle est passé par sciences po
paris avant de travailler pendant six
ans à bondy en seine-saint-denis sur
l'analyse des besoins sociaux de la
population et l'évaluation des
dispositifs de la ville j'étais assez
passionné à l'époque par et je le suis
toujours par les politiques sociales ce
qui ce qui m'a amené à me tourner vers
le terrain puisque je voulais vraiment
voir comment étaient mises en oeuvre les
politiques sociales sur le terrain des
bus 2020 elle intègre l'ena et commence
son stage dans les yvelines le 25 mai
dernier sous l'autorité du préfet sa
principale fonction accompagner les
différents acteurs de la préfecture sur
les sujets d'actualité
c'est aussi être au contact des élus
locaux des membres d'associations ou de
la population dans le cadre des
politiques de l'état
j'ai vu combien la préfecture des
yvelines était dans cette logique
d'accompagnement des collectivités
territoriales d'accompagnement des
différents partenaires pour pouvoir
faciliter l'appropriation des différents
dispositifs
là je pense qu'ils m'ont confortée
professionnellement dans mon envie de
de servir l'état au plus près des
habitants emmanuel que le plateau va
poursuivre son stage à la préfecture des
yvelines jusqu'au mois de décembre 2020